>>> OFFICIALS BELIEVE THE GUNMAN
ACCUSED OF THE MASS SHOONG IN
BUFFALO WAS INSPIRED BY THE
WHITE REPLACEMENT CONSPIRACY
THEORY, NOW, THIS IS A BASELESS
BELIEF THAT WHITE PEOPLE ARE
BEING SLOWLY BUT INTENTIONALLY
REPLACED BY MINORITIES AND
IMMIGRANTS.
>> THE CONCEPT WAS ONCE A FRINGE
THEORY BUT NOW IT'S EMBRACED BY
MANY REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS AND
FOX HOSTS.
CNN'S SUNLEN SERFATY EXPLAINS.
>> Reporter: WHAT WAS ONCE A
FRINGE WHITE SUPREMACIST
CONSPIRACY THEORY HAS NOW BECOME
MAINSTREAM.
>> JEWS WILL NOT REPLACE US.
>> WE KNOW WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE UP TO HERE.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS, THIS IS
EXACTLY THEIR STRATEGY.
THEY WANT TO REPLACE THE
AMERICAN ELECTORATE.
>> Reporter: WITH A GROWING
NUMBER OF REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
NOW OPENLY PROMOTING THE FAR
RIGHT SO-CALLED GREAT
REPLACEMENT THEORY.
>> FOR MANY AMERICANS, WHAT
SEEMS TO BE HAPPENING OR WHAT
THEY BELIEVE RIGHT NOW IS
HAPPENING IS WHAT APPEARS TO
THEM IS WE'RE REPLACING
NATIONAL-BORN AMERICAN, NATIVE
BORN AMERICANS TO PERMANENTLY
TRANSFORM THE POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE OF THIS VERY NATION.
>> Reporter: THE RACIST
ANTI-IMMIGRANT THEORY THAT SAYS
NONWHITE IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING
BROUGHT TO REPLACE AMERICA'S
WHITE POPULATION.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION WANTS
COMPLETE OPEN BORDERS AND YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHY, IS IT
REALLY THEY WANT TO REMAKE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF AMERICA.
>> DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS WHO HAVE
DECIDED THAT THEY CAN'T WIN
REELECTION IN 2022 UNLESS THEY
BRING IN A LARGE NUMBER OF NEW
VOTERS TO REPLACE THE VOTERS
THAT ARE ALREADY HERE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> Reporter: THE WHITE
NATIONALIST CONSPIRACY THEORY IS
DETAILED IN FRENCH WRITER RENOUX
CAMOU'S BOOK CALLED "THE GREAT
REPLACEMENT" MOTIVATING SOME OF
THE MOST HEINOUS MASS MURDERS IN
THE U.S. AND AROUND THE WORLD.
AN 18-YEAR-OLD MAN ACCUSED OF
SHOOTING AND KILLING TEN PEOPLE
IN A PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOOD IN NEW YORK
ALLEGEDLY WROTE A MANIFESTO
ONLINE.
THE GUNMAN ACCUSED OF KILLING
MORE THAN 20 PEOPLE IN AN EL
PASO WALMART UP LOADED A
DOCUMENT ON THE INTERNET BEFORE
THE SHOOTING SAYING QUOTE THIS
IS A RESPONSE TO THE HISPANIC
INVASION OF TEXAS.
THEY ARE THE INSTIGATORS, NOT
ME.
I AM SIMPLY DEFENDING MY COUNTRY
FROM CULTURAL AND ETHNIC
REPLACEMENT BROUGHT ON BY THE
INVASION.
THE MAN WHO ALLEGEDLY KILLED A
11 PEOPLE AT A PITTSBURGH
SYNAGOGUE IN 2018 SPOUTED
NONSENSE ON SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT
JEWISH PEOPLE BEING SOMEHOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMMIGRANT QUOTE
INVADERS.
AND THE SHOOTER WHO KILLED 51
PEOPLE AT A MOSQUE AND ISLAMIC
CENTER IN CHRIST CHURCH NEW
ZEALAND NAMED HIS OWN MANIFESTO
"THE GREAT REPLACEMENT."
THE THEORY HAS BEEN AMPLIFIED BY
VOICES ON FOX NEWS.
>> I MEAN, EVERYONE WANTS TO
MAKE A RACIAL ISSUE OUT OF IT.
THE WHITE REPLACEMENT THEORY,
NO, NO, NO, THIS IS A VOTING
RIGHTS QUESTION.
I HAVE LESS POLITICAL POWER
BECAUSE THEY'RE IMPORTING A
BRAND NEW ELECTORATE.
WHY SHOULD I SIT BACK AND TAKE
THAT.
>> Reporter: OPENLY DEFENDED BY
NAME BY SITTING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
>> THANKS SO SUNLEN SERFATY FOR
THAT.
CNN HAS FOLLOWED UP WITH A FEW
OF THOSE REPUBLICANS FOR MORE
CLARIFICATION.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
>> Reporter: SCOTT JENNINGS IS A
FORMER SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH AND CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR.
ERROL LOUIS IS A CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR.
WELCOME BACK.
WE SAW J.D. VANCE, THE OHIO
NOMINEE, SENATOR RON JOHNSON OF
WISCONSIN THERE, WE SHOWED THE
MATT GAETZ TWEET.
WHY ISN'T REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
IN CONGRESS SPEAKING OUT MORE
ABOUT THIS AGAINST THIS THEORY
THAT WE'RE HEARING SO MUCH
ABOUT?
>> WELL, THAT I THINK IF THEY
WERE SITTING HERE, THEY WOULD
PROBABLY SAY THERE'S A
CONFLATION GOING ON BETWEEN THE
RACIST, YOU KNOW, NONSENSE THAT
THIS SHOOTER SUPPOSEDLY BELIEVED
IN WHICH IS THAT JEWISH LEADERS
ARE, YOU KNOW, ORCHESTRATING
SOME BEHIND THE SCENES
REPLACEMENT VERSUS OPEN BORDERS
OR ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION DEBATE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD SAY.
THE REALITY IS WHAT EVERYONE
SHOULD SAY TODAY, REPUBLICAN,
AND I'LL SPEAK FOR MY SIDE, IS
THAT THIS THEORY IS CRAZY.
IT IS PSYCHOTIC.
IT IS RACIST, AND IT CAN INFECT
PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS GUY COULD
PICK TUCKER CARLSON OUT OF A
LINEUP.
HE SEEMS LIKE A CRAZY PERSON TO
ME.
THERE'S ONE THING TO SAY ON A
DAY LIKE TODAY, AND THAT IS TO
DENOUNCE HATE, TO DENOUNCE
RACISM, AND TO DENOUNCE ANYBODY
WHO FANS THESE FLAMES.
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID A FEW
MOMENTS AGO ABOUT THESE THINGS
DEVOLVING INTO POLITICAL DEBATE,
AND NOTHING EVER HAPPENS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS AN INCREDIBLY
POWER STATEMENT AND I THINK THE
CORRECT POLITICAL POSTURE TODAY
IS TO SAY DENOUNCING HATE WHAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING TODAY, AND
NOT ALLOWING OURSELVES TO GET
STUCK IN THE MUD IS WHAT WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON TOMORROW.
>> OF COURSE SCOTT IS RIGHT TO
DENOUNCE HATE, BUT TUCKER
CARLSON HAS A BIG PLATFORM AND
MANY NIGHTS HE TALKS ABOUT THE
WHITE REPLACEMENT THEORY.
HE'S VERY WORRIED ABOUT BEING
REPLACED APPARENTLY.
HE'S A BIG PURVEYOR OF THIS.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK THAT HAS
ALLOWED TO PERMEATE MAINSTREAM
POLITICS.
>> THAT IS THE FUNCTION OF A
TUCKER CARLSON.
HE TAKES THESE ODIOUS FRINGE
IDEAS AND IMPORTS THEM INTO THE
MAINSTREAM.
HE DOES IT WITH THE, I'M JUST
WONDERING, AND IT STACKS ONE LIE
ON ANOTHER, WHICH IS WHAT
CONSPIRACY THEORY IS ONE LIE
STACKED ON TOP OF ANOTHER,
PLAYING TO THE WORST INSTINCTS,
YOU KNOW, MEDIA LEADERSHIP JUST
LIKE POLITICAL LEADERSHIP
REQUIRES AN ELEMENT OF
RESPONSIBILITY, OF TAKING
SERIOUSLY ONE'S OBLIGATION TO
TELL THE TRUTH AND TO SPEAK THE
TRUTH, EVEN IF IT'S NOT
POLITICALLY CONVENIENT, EVEN IF
IT LOSES YOU A FEW VIEWERS.
EVEN IF IT COSTS YOU A COUPLE OF
RATINGS POINTS.
NOT EVERYBODY BELIEVES THAT,
THOUGH.
WHAT THEY DO IS PLAY TO THE
WORST INSTINCTS OF HUMANITY FOR
A MOMENTARY GAIN.
IT'S FOLLY ON ONE LEVEL, IT'S
DESPICABLE AS FAR AS THE
OUTCOME, AND THE OUTCOME IS NOW
HERE FOR ALL OF US TO SEE.
THERE'S A REASON THAT THE WORD
DEMAGOGUE IS AN ANCIENT WORD.
THIS IS A PROBLEM OF HUMAN
NATURE, PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF
POWER WITH A PLATFORM, WITH A
VOICE, USING IT FOR ALL OF THE
WORST REASONS.
>> SCOTT, YOU SAID THAT TODAY IS
THE DAY TO CONDEMN HATE, AND
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS THE DAY TO DO THAT, BUT
WHAT'S THE DAY THAT WE TALK
ABOUT HOW TO STOP DOING THIS,
OFTEN WHEN WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
IN MANY RESPECTS THE DAY AFTER.
TODAY IS NOT THE DAY FOR THAT.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE QUESTION OF
GUNS IN THIS COUNTRY, NOW IS A
TIME TO SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY WE
HEAR.
BUT WHAT'S THE DAY THAT WE TALK
ABOUT HOW TO STOP THIS
LEGISLATIVELY.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, AS I'VE BEEN
SIFTING THROUGH THE NEWS STORIES
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR SHOOTER,
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS PERSON
YET, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT JUST
CONTINUES TO JUMP OUT AT ME,
VICTOR, IS THE FACT THAT
APPARENTLY AND ALLEGEDLY, I
GUESS, ACCORDING TO THE
REPORTING, HE HAD MADE SOME
NOISE LAST YEAR ABOUT BEING
VIOLENT AT SCHOOL, SHOOTING UP A
SCHOOL, AND THAT PEOPLE KNEW
ABOUT THIS, THAT THERE WERE
NOTIFICATIONS ABOUT THIS.
AND I JUST -- WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS A FEW YEARS AGO, THE IDEA
THAT IF SOMEONE MAKES A SPECIFIC
THREAT, A VIOLENT THREAT THAT
SOMEHOW THAT COULD GET TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT AS WE MONITOR THEIR
FUTURE BEHAVIOR AND THE FACT
THAT THIS PERSON OBVIOUSLY THEY
JUST FELL RIGHT THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
TO ME, IF I WERE IN A POSITION
OF AUTHORITY THAT'S WHERE I
WOULD BE TRYING TO FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT, IS HOW CAN
SOMEBODY GO FROM POSSIBLY
ENGAGING IN A SCHOOL SHOOTING TO
OBVIOUSLY ENGAGING IN AN ACTUAL
SHOOTING JUST A FEW MONTHS
LATER, AND IT WAS NEVER FOLLOWED
UP ON.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT.
IT STRIKES ME THAT'S THE FASTEST
AND MOST OBVIOUS THING TO LOOK
AT AS YOU'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
THESE KINDS OF THINGS FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE.
>> HERE AGAIN, OBVIOUSLY, IT'S
COMMON SENSE.
IT MAKES SUCH SENSE, IF YOU HAVE
THREATENED YOUR SCHOOL WITH I
THINK POLICE HAVE CALLED IT A
MURDER/SUICIDE PLOT, THAT SHOULD
BE FLAGGED SOMEWHERE, BUT THIS
GUY PASSED A BACKGROUND CHECK,
THIS 18-YEAR-OLD, THE GUN SHOP
OWNER SOLD HIM THE GUN AS FAR AS
WE KNOW LEGALLY BECAUSE SOMEONE
THAT'S NOT IN AN IMPORTANT
DATABASE.
>> IT'S NOT A SMALL TWEAK THAT'S
NEEDED, IT'S REALLY A
RECONCEPTUALIZATION OF ALL OF
THIS.
WE HAVE 21st COMMUNICATIONS
TECHNOLOGY, 21st CENTURY
WEAPONS, LIKE APPARENTLY SOME OF
THE WEAPONRY THAT WAS USED.
HE CAN LIVE STREAM AT THE SAME
TIME, WHICH IS AN AMAZING AMOUNT
OF TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE HAVE 19th CENTURY LAWS
AND TRADITIONS AND POLICIES.
WE'VE GOT TO SORT OF, THIS IS
WHAT LEADERSHIP REQUIRES.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE A MATCH
BETWEEN WHAT IT IS WE WANT AND
THE ENORMOUS POWER THAT WE GIVE
TO ALL OF OUR CITIZENS,
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE EVIL OR
DEMENTED OR MISGUIDED OR CALLING
OUT FOR HELP, FRANKLY.
WE BLEW IT THIS TIME, AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING OTHER THAN
THE USUAL, YOU KNOW, HEARTS AND
PRAYERS OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
WE'VE GOT TO SORT OF DO SOME
SERIOUS GOVERNING, SOME SERIOUS